since you're very proactive what do you
do to drum up work in between projects
well you know my day job I've been lucky
enough to be able to write as a day job
so I'm constantly scouring you know the
world looking for rewrite jobs and you
know things like that but you know
recently I haven't had time to do
anything like that like we had to sit on
six months rule for several months while
we waited for the right festival to to
accept us and it ended up being the
Austin Film Festival which is an amazing
experience a great festival um but
during that time I was just sitting so I
was writing a bunch and you know doing a
bunch of work for other people whatever
came down the pipe really and now since
we played Austin we haven't stopped like
we you know got our distribution all
packaged up during those months that i
was going from one festival to another
to another and it was a really fun time
but like we haven't I haven't stopped
moving so I need a job is what I'm
saying um or I need six month or rule to
do really really well well before six
months rule and all the stuff that's
coming along with it what was your daily
routine like us you seem like you're
very discipline thank you yeah I'll take
that and you know I try to write in the
morning every day and go to the gym
every day in Babylon 5 days a week and
um but other than that it's it's
loosey-goosey you know it's trying to be
proactive like you say and keep keep the
motor going you know trying to keep
things going i usually have a list of
stuff you know like most producers have
these that I know have these lists of
phone calls they have to make every day
and well I got a bug the lawyer again
because he hasn't called me back and I
gotta call this guy and hit him up for
you know financing for something you
know I mean they're all these not
artistic not fun menial things that you
gotta do just to keep things running so
and do a lot of that but I have fun to
do you choose a certain time of day
because I know for myself sometimes
I just have to plow through it like I
don't want to do some of those not a fun
creative things but that's such a huge
part of the work yeah people don't
realize that so do you have a certain
time of day or when you're in a good
mood or how do you just attack some so
the mood leaves pretty quickly and you
know i am doing that no I tried you know
I try to get up early and and hit as
much as I can you know and then but like
I said you know I I also give myself a
break like you know I'll go see a movie
in the middle of the day and then come
back and you know go back to it but
hitting deadlines is very important to
me because obviously we rely on other
people Aidan get one so trying to get
things taken care of in a timely manner
is it's just so important and it's so
difficult because you have to everything
you have to pull and you know I I the
people in my office get tired to be
talking about how nobody I've no one has
emailed me back i sent 15 emails today
and that one person has written me back
and i have nothing to do until somebody
writes me back so uh you know cry me a
river right I'm not digging ditches but
it's a it's frustrating and but it's
part of the day like exactly he said
it's it's part of the job and that's why
it's okay for the job to be so much fun
and so cool because you've earned it
you